buccaneers advance to the nfc
championship game
and chris i don't know who to say more
about between brady and breeze let me
just say this about brady
it dawned on me last night since 2011
he's played in the conference
championship of his conference
every year except one 2019. that's a 90
success rate of getting to the
conference championship
round something the dallas cowboys
haven't done
since the 1995 season five years
before tom brady even entered the league
he has made it
to nine of the last 10 final fours in
the nfl
that to me is one of the most incredible
accomplishments
in any sport that i can recall it really
is good morning
i mean it's it's unreal really i mean
that what you just said there you know
like you said 14 years of conference
championship games like
are you kidding me we got great all-time
hall-of-famers
who have had 14-year careers
with one or two conference championship
games
and really only three or four playoff
appearances in general
let alone to have a whole careers worth
of conference championship games i mean
that that's just to me is
it's amazing uh it just tells you what
he is
a lot of credit to the buccaneers and
what they did this year i mean it was
not
easy with tom brady coming to town all
of that it's amazing
and brady is amazing we've never seen
anybody
as consistently this good for this long
ever in this sport i know i don't say
he's the greatest quarterback ever but
for that
argument right there i've never seen
anybody play at this high of a level for
this long
that's not even close i'll certainly
give him that for sure
when it was 20 to 20 in the second half
and you could begin to feel the weight
oh yeah you felt it of the game right
saints were saints you could feel that
everything got real real tight for the
saints
and and that's when it doesn't get tight
for a guy
who has been there right who has 43
now postseason games in his career think
about that he's closing in on
three full seasons just of playoff games
so
when it's all coming to that and it
reminds me of the old bill parcells line
when he's
trying to get the giants going yelling
this is why you do all that work this is
why you lift all that weight
everything you do everything you do
all year long every day of getting up
at 5am or earlier than that to show up
to the facility so you're there before
anyone else and all that crap that he
eats that
i'm sure you eventually acquire a taste
for it but it probably takes a while
and all the hydration everything he does
to apply ability and all that
it all comes down to that hour
and change where the season's riding on
it and that's why in that setting i'll
take him over anybody else
anybody else now patrick mahomes has
that kind of
like loose quality where he's not
affected in that moment
but brady has that hardened steely
and it and it what we saw last night
it infects the rest of the team because
what happened
the defense provided the spark the
defense
started to clamp down on the saints the
defense after giving up the touchdown to
start
the third quarter that made it 20 to 13.
the defense put the clamps on the saints
and i think that is a direct result of
having tom brady on your sideline well i
mean all of it is i mean
it just you know like we've always
talked from the start
he's a guy that gives the organization
confidence
you know right from the get-go so
there's a belief that they can win any
football game
and then you know i think what you're
speaking to and that confidence that we
feel with him
he's just like got the greatest
risk reward governor in the history of
football basically
where you just feel like man in those
moments when the game is tight or
they're down by just a little or up by a
little
you know he has the way to be aggressive
and still oh man we gotta worry about
everything
but not like crazy to where he's gonna
throw the ball into second you know
double or triple coverage or anything
like that
he will you know take the underneath her
out and do the smart thing
but he's not going to turn down the big
plays and i think that's where he's so
dangerous and
you know again last night really the
game last night was
the stories brady i know that the nfc
championship
all that to me the story of the game is
the buccaneers
a little what you just said the
physicality and more than anything
no risk it no biscuit bruce aryans
they ran the ball like that that was the
key to the game
they played a game that they felt like
it might not be pretty
i don't like coaching it this way but
this is our best chance to win this game
and to me that's something i haven't
seen bruce arians do at throughout his
whole career
he wasn't always willing to sacrifice
deep throws and deep bombs and things
like that
phenomenal game plan and then of course
you got brady who's the all-time
commander and orchestrating that that
game plan
the split came down to 35 rushing
attempts 33 passes now there were some
mountains in there as well tom brady
ended up with five attempts most of
those were dropping to a knee
but still leonard fournette who got the
start and i just didn't think we were
going to see ronald jones and then we
see ronald jones in the second half and
he gave that offense the spark that it
needed
and and that you know and and and he had
the long run that was nullified by a
holding penalty in the second half
and he seemed to aggravate his injured
quad and i thought that's it we're not
going to see him again and it's a shame
that happened at buccaneers the play
gets wiped out
he comes back i mean again this is that
reservoir of
your whole season comes down to this and
when you have a guy
whose entire career has been made on
your whole season comes down to this
you get swept up in that too i really do
think
that is the tangible and intangible
value
of having 12 on your sideline who's been
there
who's done it and you want to rise to
the moment with a guy who you know
rises to the moment every time sure
almost
except last year against the titans wild
card round who rises to the moment yeah
he didn't have anybody around
everybody around him right but he has
he's got plenty of guys around him and
that defense
when they look antoine winfield junior
he had the opportunity at the
interception and what's he do he rips
the ball out from jared cook
devon white recovers it and returns it
that was the spark to tie the game up
and then the defense didn't look back
from there devin white
if he plays like he played in the second
half for the rest of the first season
they're winning the super bowl chris he
was if you can play like that
for for eight more quarters they're
winning the super bowl well it you know
their defense of course does deserve a
lot of credit i mean yeah we hit the
offense bruce arians all that stuff but
you know the defense yeah saints moved
the ball on them a little bit okay
alvin kamara had a few nice runs and all
that but as the game settled in
and once they got a feel for like okay
the saints
all right this is how they're going to
attack us all right we got our feet
underneath us the nerves are done
i mean they got right in the face of the
new orleans saints and the saints were
you know incapable of really making a
big play
or doing anything you know they had
nothing to back up
the tampa bay buccaneers and this is you
know honestly this is a common theme
we've talked about with the saints at
the end of every year
it's the same type of thing but yes
devon white
antoine winfield those guys not having
to back up making plays
constantly coming downhill hill playing
aggressive
uh the defense was was phenomenal of
course the turnovers were the key to the
football game the fact that they did
that
you don't ever see drew brees and sean
payton turn the ball over that way
especially in these kind of moments and
it was uh it was bad it was a bad look
yesterday that's for sure
we got some sound to listen to since you
mentioned drew brees and sean payton
regarding the turnovers let's shift to
that because the turnovers were a huge
factor three interceptions from drew
brees his first three interception game
since 2016 chris the last of three years
where they didn't make the playoffs
right they made the playoffs four
straight times for the first time in
franchise history and they
exit for the fourth straight time here's
drew brees and sean payton after the
game regarding the turnovers from breeze
unfortunately you know
those type of things in a game like this
end up being
being the difference and um
you know they scored three touchdowns
off of our first three turnovers and
it's just tough to win a game uh
you know against a good team like that
when you do that i'd say it's
pretty uncharacteristic because we all
we preach
you know playing winning football and
you turn the ball over
four times um so you're minus four total
in the turnover ratio then that's that's
not winning football especially in the
playoffs especially against the team
like that
and it wasn't just breeds it was the
jared cook fumble and that was the spark
that gave the buccaneers the opportunity
to tie the game because
after the the saints went up 20 to 13
the buccaneers punted
it was that drive when the saints got it
back where the buccaneers defense woke
up and antoine
the game made that play the game you you
feel like it's 20 to 13
and the bucks you know as much as we
just sang their praises for running the
football we're not a machine on the
offensive side of the ball
so you're going 20 to 13 and really the
bucks only scoring drive
came off the first interception which
was the three yard pass
and you're going man they go down two
scorers i don't know if this bucks
team's gonna be able to drive down
two times and score a touchdown on this
buck uh saints defense
so i mean that really the interception's
bad
but the saints are on the
way to go up two scores maybe kick a
field goal maybe scored
go up two touchdowns and really put the
bucks in a tough tough spot
i mean that was maybe the play of the
playoffs to this point as far as
one guy saving their team and the game
was never never the same after that mike
you're exactly right
changed the game bucks never looked back
never felt like
the saints ever regained momentum or
were
really even a threat to win the game
after that play
three touchdowns for the buccaneers
covered 63 yards that's crazy after
those
turnovers it's a lot easier to score
touchdowns so you don't have to go very
far
how about this too we mentioned leonard
fournette and ronald jones with 30
carries
antonio brown mike evans and rob
gronkowski had one
catch each for the game now brown was
injured
the fox broadcast showed him favoring a
leg in the first half we didn't see him
much in the second half
if at all evans had the three yard
touchdown on marshawn lattimore but he
otherwise was taken away and rob
gronkowski had a catch down near the
goal line
near the end of the game but you know
there was a throw to gronk in the end
zone at one point he just lumbers he
still has not regained the explosion
that he used to have and he now says he
wants to play one more year
as long as he knows his role then he's
going to be a year older and he's going
to have even less of that
that burst that we used to see he's he's
kind of just like a
blocker now that that every once in a
while does something in the passing game
a far cry from what he used to be but
but he you know he made contributions in
the blocking department yesterday and it
helps open up that running game when
they stick to it and they did stick to
it
okay bruce arians devin white right
let's hear from them because
in in victory there's still a little
saltiness from the buccaneers
i mean we have to look at ourselves in
the mirror and you know we just have to
challenge ourselves on who we wanted to
be you know everybody always asks what
was our identity
and you know we didn't have a household
but
coach b.a he had an answer he said we
were going to find a way to win the game
and that was the best thing that i ever
heard yeah it's a different football
team than that week
trying to tell everybody that nobody
wants to believe it but uh you know um
yeah this is what we're capable playing
defensively uh we've had some
some rough spots at times but we've had
some really really good times and uh
this is one of the best times
you can't tell variance has a cut on his
nose or he's pulled out the old
breathing
breathe right just get a little thanks
yeah he might be it might be like that
damn mask because
it's really claustrophobic in there i
need a little extra air let me get a
breathe right on there
opening up the nasal passages my god
everybody wore those things
for a period of time in the 90s uh but
uh
anyway well look the buccaneers the
buccaneers had potential all year long i
picked him to win the super bowl yes he
did
so right so i'm gonna ride i'm gonna
ride that i already tell you i'm picking
them to win this weekend i can't abandon
the horse now just like you can't
abandon the chiefs now against your boy
blue no you pick them to win the super
bowl you can't get off that horse even
if they don't have patrick mahomes
you're locked in
we'll talk about that game coming up
obviously but look
this is exactly what the buccaneers
wanted to do they did have the
expectations too high early on
and and i think the rest of us expected
too much
but you got 18 games in now it's a
different team
than the team that started the season
and as we saw a far different team
than the team that got blown off the
field by the saints in week nine
after losing both games in the regular
season they win the one that matters
no they won the one that matters that's
right we saw you said it the potential
all year
i i know we sat here the monday or was
it the tuesday
after the the bucks and raiders played
and we went
the bucks can win the super bowl we sat
here and said
this team when they're playing at their
best matches up with anybody and they
had just beat the raiders and blown out
the packers a week before that
and yeah they went through a lull in the
middle of the year where they kind of
lost
their way or weren't quite figuring out
how they wanted to play and package
their offense and do those things
but since the bye week it's been nothing
but
one great offensive performance after
another the defense has been really damn
good
and you know last night they show a
little versatility
on the offensive side of the ball
winning the winning the game that way in
a different way
defense running the football that way
mike i still
i can't get over bruce erin's and byron
leftwich i really can't
you know they're they're famous for
wanting to be aggressive and throw the
football
and they really played a game in where
they went
you know like we don't trust our pass
game
we're not gonna let them get strip
sacked fumbles
and pressure brady or make him feel
pressure and throw a bad throw down the
field into coverage like he did in the
first two games
they they played a totally different
style i didn't know if they were willing
to sacrifice that to win the game
i really didn't and that's where i mean
i really give bruce aaron's and byron
leffridge
a lot of credit for playing the complete
football game as a team
and saying this is the way we need to
win as a team and they went out there
and did that and that was that to me was
amazing that aryans had that in them
and you mentioned byron leftwich yeah
yeah he has not been interviewed why
anyone how does like calvin winslow get
interviewed and byron leftwich does no
one talks to him right
i mean ellen moore sorry yeah i was
gonna say kellen winslow it's like
nobody talks to him nobody's talking to
him no there's a reason why
we got lots of reasons there's a reason
there's a reason why he's not available
to be interviewed and he never got into
coaching
but uh yeah leftwich the eagles
reportedly are going to talk to todd
bowles
if you're going to talk to todd bowles
talk to buyer and left she needs
somebody to fix your quarterback
situation
and look at what leftwich has done so
far in his career and he's a guy that
the bruce arians has been grooming the
texans as they and we're going to talk
about that coming up in the show as they
try to fix this thing with deshaun
watson it would just
i don't think it would hurt it's not
going to make it any worse if you take a
look at byron left which
but the buccaneers are getting it done
and you know one of the
one of the things that that uh we wrote
going into the weekend
the idea that the saints had beaten the
buccaneers twice and it is
actually easier to win the third game
than to lose the third game and
bill parcells used to say the team that
lost both times
thinks it can win the third game the
team that won both times
knows it can win the third game and
that's relevant to sunday
because the buccaneers and the packers
met once right and it was a 38 to 10
shellacking the buccaneers
know they can beat the packers now in
green bay
in january in the snow right maybe a
different vibe
right but but chris that that that's
that's an advantage that the packers are
going to have to overcome
no no doubt i mean they're going to have
but you know they'll have the fear
factor on their side this week where
like whoa this team beat us we better
get on our stuff this week and you know
dot our eyes and cross our tees and do
all that
you know and then hey they'll be able to
point at the bucks and just go
listen this team got blown out by the
saints
at the end of this or you know a little
past the midway point of the year
they continued to improve as a football
team and then they went to the saints
and beat their butt in their stadium
the packers could say the same thing to
their football team matt lafleur
he could sit there and go we're not the
same team that went to tampa and
we're a totally different team now we're
tougher on defense we're more physical
our run game is borderline unstoppable
so
this is going to be amazing it's going
to be the battle of will's brady
determination
mr johnny cool calm clutch and then
aaron rodgers
who crap he just wants to you know
get to another super bowl just get there
he's got the pressure of
trying to add on to his legacy and stop
brady from just piling on to his legacy
and
you know in this matchup i i think you
know rogers will feel more the pressure
in this than brady because of that
aspect
yeah and look at that tom brady 14
conference championship starts
twice as many as joe montana who's in
second place
with seven we never saw brady and rogers
in a super bowl
we always thought we would they were one
year apart
it was 45 for rogers 46 for brazil
damn onside kick in seattle we would
have had it but you know
yeah that's true we had it we were so
close
the the uh the but still it's as big of
a game as it gets without getting to the
super bowl and the winner is going to be
facing either patrick with homes or josh
allen
or chad henny we'll talk about that
again coming up let's flip it over
though to the saints and let's give some
appreciation for drew brees because by
all appearances
it was his last game jay glazer of fox
reported before the game and
glazer has a very solid pipeline into
the saints organization that it is drew
brees final game
and when sean payton says in his press
conference after the game when he's
asked about brees
that's a subject for another press
conference
that means he's done folks you don't
have a press conference to say you're
not done
you have the press conference to say
it's over
breeze was more vanilla but
yeah it's it's done he lingered out on
the field for an hour after the game
there he is with tom brady he's playing
with his kids and i think he went even
went back
out after the media portion of his
evening was look at that
brady's throwing balls that
that is really cool that brady's i mean
that's as cool as it gets right there
sorry good throw good coverage good
catch just like the traequan smith
touchdown
and let me tell you the the second one
the traequan smith touchdown that put
the saints up 20 to 13
was a great great throw by breeze there
wasn't much of an opening
he put it there and that's that's what
the buccaneers had to overcome
you're in the superdome on their turf
they drive down the field
they go up seven the clock is starting
to move toward that
period of we don't got a whole lot of
time left and and they stiffened and it
was the defense the the side of the ball
that you wouldn't expect on a tom brady
team to stiffen
and and and deliver the turning point
and and brady just took it from there
yeah but but
back to breeze first battle hall of
famer without question there was a time
a few years ago where people were like i
don't know if his first battle hall of
famer of course he is the question is
where is he in the in the pantheon of
all-time great quarterbacks i you may
disagree with me i have him in the top
10 at least maybe the top
seven i don't know about the top five i
used to think maybe top five
i don't know you got to sit down and
make the whole list it's hard to do it
in a vacuum
you need to start listing names right
one of the all-time great nfl careers
and
and overcoming the obstacle they
mentioned on the broadcast last night
none of the schools in his home state of
texas
wanted him because he had to stand on
his tippy toes to get to six feet
yeah no i mean i remember i was at texas
not long after
you know his he's still playing college
football when i was at texas people were
talking about that constantly down there
we let somebody in from austin westlake
they let him out of town you know yeah
because they didn't think he was capable
of playing at the university of texas
which they obviously were wrong
like amazing career you're right first
ballot hall of famer
i mean one of the most accurate passers
we've ever seen in the sport
everything he did the way he's handled
himself well
it's all through the roof i mean it
really is and
you know it's a shame that it has to end
this way but this is the way it ends for
most for most great
football players other than you know a
handful in the history of the sport
but you know what we saw last night is
is why the career has to end a little
bit too though
you know it's just when the game got
down by 10 points and the way tampa was
playing you kind of just knew like there
was no way they were gonna come back
you could tell that tampa could run with
you know the saints receivers to a
degree
and they weren't worried about having to
run with them down the field for any
explosive type patterns or routes or
things that way and that's ultimately
what's hurt brees over the last few
years
is that aspect but man leadership
you know toughness the ability to play
the game i mean it's all through the
roof and like you said
definite first ballot hall of famer
and when you consider the fact that he
was tied
to sean payton as long as he was because
look the results were mixed early in the
career
first he had to overcome doug flutie
then it was his job then they draft
philip rivers which means they're done
with drew brees eventually
he has the horrible shoulder injury in
his final regular season game in the
2005 season
in san diego at the time then you know
there's the whole question what are the
dolphins gonna do they take dante
culpepper with the rec knee instead of
drew brees
breeze lands in new orleans and and and
that's when it all just explodes and
that's the benefit
and we're gonna talk presumably coming
up about some of these coaching
decisions but
chris i'm i'm on the record it's well
established
you tie a quarterback to a head coach
who can
be his guy he can be his sean payton for
15 years sure
that helped drew brees tremendously
you know brees never got back to a super
bowl rogers is trying to get back to a
super bowl
there are fundamental differences
between the two passers the two from the
from
but but having sean payton the benefit
of peyton's brain
for the past 15 years is one of the
reasons why brees is one of the all-time
greats
yeah big reasons i don't take anything
away from breeze no but it's that
combination
and and that helped brees get to where
he is it's amazing well every
you know i almost feel like every great
quarterback for the most part had some
semblance of that i know that's not all
the way true through through and through
but hey sean payton certainly to me
is more a part of that conversation than
maybe any other quarterback
coach combination in the history of the
sport yeah peyton's amazing
he's as creative as we've ever seen in
this sport he's as smart as we've ever
seen anything like that
and i think that also yeah to a degree
we'll
have people question how great drew
brees is because people know how awesome
sean payton is so that detracts a little
bit
you know from him sure just like people
will do that with brady and belichick
but you know brady of course is gonna
silence some of that right now with
what's going on
so but but that's that's that's common
nature either way they're synonymous
with
unbelievable passing attacking
cutting-edge offense that we've never
seen before
and it was special it's crazy that only
really resulted into one super bowl
appearance but still
it was awesome and it was special that's
for sure and you've gotten the sense the
past few years that sean payton is ready
to move on to someone who can get the
ball down the field and and the play
that
first gave the saints a lift was that
borrowing exactly copying right stealing
of the bears play
that didn't work because javon williams
didn't catch the ball
but it was jameis winston who came into
the game split wide to the right
got the ball eventually through to a
wide open traequan smith down the field
and and uh that that's the thing last
night that
that i think really helps us get to the
conclusion
sean payton's sean payton's ready for
the new
challenge and also the new opportunity
whether it's jameis winston taysom hill
or both to get the ball down the
football field because drew brees just
hasn't been able to do it the past few
years no not that he ever was a guy who
would rock it at 70 yards but
he could scare you it makes it makes the
the accomplishments even more impressive
that you know this isn't a guy with a
giant josh allen patrick
holmes arm but he still was able to walk
away with almost every record although
brady's eventually going to have him
because we know he's going to keep going
and he'll have the yardage record and
he'll have the touchdown record and
he'll have all the records by the time
he's done chris
the league's changed you know it you
know it's not the nfl from 10 years ago
where
you know the dink and dunk and the wide
receiver screens and everything like
that
you know you could be really successful
and
really not have to make big plays that
way that's the seattle scheme the
seattle defense changed that
the eight guys at the line of scrimmage
they took away all those short passes
and everything's changed ever since then
and the game now is you know you've
heard me say this over the last few
weeks
it's about homers and strikeouts it's
about big plays
and what we've seen from the saints with
brees here the last few years
they become a team that's got to hit a
lot of singles to win the game
single single single single single
single and it's just too hard to do that
and play all football
you know their inability to create big
plays or take pressure off the offense
the last few years has been their
biggest problem
yeah their last three playoff losses i
mean you could certainly sit here and
argue and go no they were the better
team on the field
all three games they were the better
team they just did not capitalize
and not play their best and not make big
plays to ever
flip the field or take pressure off
their team that way
and that's unfortunate it really is but
yeah i mean you could really say really
the last four playoff losses
even in minnesota i could sit there and
argue i think the saints were the better
team on the field that day
they just you know didn't make the plays
to win the football game especially with
the minnesota miracle and all that
this is a scaled down version of what
the bills did
from 90 to 93. the bill's using the
super bowl and getting back to the super
bowl every single year the saints
losing in heartbreaking fashion each of
the first three times they're in the
playoffs getting back every year and
they're the first team ever to win
49 games most wins over a four-year span
without getting to a super bowl wow
that's a testament to their ability to
reset and begin the climb again out of
what dennis green called the valley of
zero and zero and they're going to do it
next year without drew brees
another guy that that they may be doing
it without is michael thomas who had
zero catches and
i saw something on twitter last night
and if he tweeted it he deleted it
someone posted a screenshot of him
retweeting one of desean watson's recent
salty tweets i think it was the one
where he says i was on two now i'm on
ten
and it was retweeted based upon the
image i saw by michael thomas with
same uh as the message
so you know there's been this lingering
sense of weird
function and disharmony and and you know
somebody pointed out to me last week i
don't know where i saw it and i wish i
remembered so i could give the person
the proper credit
now that urban meyer is in the nfl it
could be that michael thomas wants to
make a beeline to jacksonville
because meyer was his coach and the guy
who recruited him to ohio state so
that's something to keep an eye on
now that urban meyer's in there's going
to be some and there's like 57 ohio
state guys currently in the nfl some of
those guys may want to try to get to
jacksonville one way or the other
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports